i think we might be the only four people  who've ever seen like the actual ship  yeah our ancestors came over one so  that's really a unique situation  all of the ships engaged in this trade  the thousands over the 400 years  to date this is the only one  found now and identified that is so  intact that we're the first people in  that space since your ancestors left  [Music]  what makes this very powerful and it's  chilling in this aspect is that that  hold where those 110 people were placed  survives so that we go into it we have  the understanding of being the first  people in there since those captives  it's not ironic that the four of us are  here witnessing this at this point in  time  and there's a responsibility that we  carry and i think there's also a  privilege to be able to even see this to  witness this oh yes  honor and a privilege it is